now given that Republicans are going to
take control of the house in what a
month or so it's obscene to think that
Congress is planning to make Majors
legislative changes before Pelosi has to
give up the gavel but as we warned you
last week Democrats are going to try to
take advantage of the few weeks
remaining to Ram through as much
sweeping change as possible
now in one of the most cynical swampy
manners possible official Washington
wants to sneak legislation through under
the cover of the Holiday Rush and
trumped up government shutdown fears for
weeks the Pentagon has been sending not
so subtle messages to Congress that
failure to act on the National Defense
authorization act and nominable spending
bills puts that puts us at a strategic
and disadvantage if the current budget
extension extends Beyond December we may
be forced to reduce accessions impairing
our ability to meet our missions and our
ability to recruit Personnel well that's
scary well I wonder were there any
policy decisions taken by the Pentagon
and the Biden Administration that could
have led to a recruiting crisis in our
military
secretary Austin has been very clear
that he opposes uh the repeal of the
vaccine vaccine mandate and the
president actually concurs uh with uh
with the Secretary of Defense
um he he continues to believe that all
Americans including those in the armed
forces should be vaccinated and boosted
for covid-19
and boosted and another uh excuse we've
heard is that we need more spending to
keep up with inflation
well I don't know much how much time
they need to spend on the iron irony
behind that argument but it seems like
the pressure from the White House and
the Pentagon is resonating with some
Senate Republicans
I just finished a meeting with the
Republican leader about finding a
constructive path forward to keep the
government funded next fiscal year we're
going to continue negotiations until we
get the job done on funding the
government both sides recognize the
importance so now both sides must chart
a path forward together
forward now that line may work in a
Nicholas Sparks movie but it's no way to
run a government the only ones who are
optimistic here are the lobbyists and
the consultants for big business voters
may not have given Republicans majority
in the Senate but they certainly didn't
vote for stealth giveaways either
now this defense bill will as usual be
so long and the texts released so late
that few members will actually read it
and even fewer tally up all the waste
but Breitbart uncovered something
disturbing tucked inside it something
called the journalism competition and
preservation act in the National Defense
authorization act now it will allow
media companies most owned by wealthy
conglomerates to form negotiating
cartels to secure special favors from
Big tech companies including some
Financial handouts and it goes from bad
to worse by the way the marijuana Lobby
thank you John Boehner also gets a huge
financial boost in the bill no more
government prohibitions on Banking and
doing business with banks with cannabis
related businesses
I'm also a co-sponsor of the safe
Banking Act which would allow financial
institutions to offer banking services
to legally operated cannabis Business
Without Fear of punishment by federal
regulators
okay now don't for a second think that
they hadn't planned this all along now
staff on the hill and at the White House
undoubtedly have been working away on
all of this nonsense for probably most
of the last year
take what happened last week when French
president Emmanuel macron visited the
White House who who in his right mind
actually thinks that the Biden team
didn't know what he was going to say in
protest about the made in America
provisions and that so-called inflation
reduction act now there were certain
subsidies that were supposed to be
eligible eligible for American companies
uh or if you had signed a free trade
deal with the United States you'd get
subsidies in those two cases now the EU
does not qualify obviously it's not an
American company and they don't have a
free trade deal with the United States
but the EU still wants the benefits so
when macron comes over to complain that
European exports would be hurt
Biden did not stand up for American
workers or American Manufacturing he
immediately gave in and agreed that
there would be glitches in the bill that
would be fixed by the way this is the
bill that he and the Democrats had just
campaigned on
make more cars and semiconductors in
America
more infrastructure and innovation in
America I believe we can own the future
of the automobile Market Detroit is back
America's back instead of relying on
foreign Supply chains Let's Make It in
America
he didn't mean that at the time so now
instead of making America great again
we're making France great again
meanwhile back on the hill The Usual
Suspects and the GOP are trying to pass
legislation that you don't want and
again they didn't campaign on fake
Republican senator Tom Tillis who has
always railed against limits on foreign
workers is working with Democrat Kirsten
Cinema to finalize a permanent giveaway
to companies who want as much cheap
labor as possible now you're supposed to
believe that Tillis out of his deep
patriotic concern for the nation is
working overtime to fix our current
border woes The Washington Post lays it
on thick saying besides protecting two
million dreamers the cinema until this
draft would allocate money for border
security the hiring of more officers and
pay raises for agents okay this is a
total lie
Biden's DHS could be doing the Border
enforcement right now but of course they
refused to and instead they're waving in
as many illegals into the country as
possible
so negotiating with the White House on
immigration now is like negotiating with
a hostage taker title 42 is lifted on
May 23rd what does success for your plan
look like if it works as you intend
success looks like it looks like the
orderly implementation of our plan where
we are applying our laws in accordance
with their Provisions in a way that
respects individuals rights to claim
Asylum
of course they're acting in bad faith
how else do you describe the actions of
officials who actively subvert title 42
which you may remember allowed for
immediate border turnbacks because of
the pandemic remember Biden still says
we're in a National Emergency because of
the pandemic
and how many times by the way have they
all told us that the border is secure
that's the best joke ever
the reality is they want open borders
period end of story
the amnesty will come to 2 million
dreamers but that will just be a magnet
and the enforcement never will follow
it will simply mean more illegals lining
up along the Rio Grande
now just last month more than 73 000
gotaways those are illegals were able to
get into the United States without being
apprehended across the border
that is the highest number ever recorded
yeah definitely do a deal with those
guys
so for about 17 years now the bipartisan
establishment has been trying to
convince you that we need to weaken our
immigration rules even further
we cannot build a unified country by
inciting people to anger
or playing on anyone's fears or
exploiting the issue of immigration for
political gain it is long past time to
reform
an immigration system that right now
doesn't serve America as well as it
should the immigration reform is
supported by everyone from labor unions
the religious leaders to the U.S Chamber
of Commerce
let's get it
sent for all
now your humble host has fought against
this for most of the last 20 years I
warned the Bush Administration what
would happen if they didn't follow
through on enforcement
and look who's been forced out of
politics since the bushes Boehner Cantor
Liz Cheney Pat Toomey and the list goes
on and on and on
and this new proposal is no better than
any of the others that crashed and
burned in fact it's the worst because it
comes at a time of unprecedented border
crashing and whether we're in a
recession now or we'll be certain you
know certainly soon that's terrible and
by the way real wages are already
falling in the United States it's
terrible timing
now they know you would vote against it
if you could yet they simply don't care
this cabal that hates the populace and
hated the Tea Party knows where these
immigration efforts will always end up
if they're introduced in the regular
legislative session
this is the reason for their hidden ball
trick on amnesty right now
they know none of it's popular that if
they had to openly run on it it probably
would have cost them the Senate the
Democrats so the Democrats are hoping
that by the time 2024 rolls around
you'll have forgotten what they did to
Ram through all this runaway spending
immigration amnesty eviscerating made in
America fast tracking pot use and
insulating the woke Pentagon from
scrutiny but we will not forget and that
is the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else